I live in New York state,
one of many where
politicians spend more money than we have.
There’s a $4.4 billion dollar deficit.
My governor wants to raise taxes,
but this man says
there's a better way to raise money.
We can lease naming rights on our infrastructure.
We can use…
Infrastructure meaning…
Bridges, tunnels,
The Triborough bridge could be called
the Staples Bridge,
or the Apple Bridge.
Companies would pay
because bridges are seen by lots of people.
Hundreds of thousands of vehicles pass by,
and see that big sign.
That’s valuable.
That I disagree with.
That's a bad idea.
Most people we asked didn’t like the idea.
I definitely wouldn't want to rename something
after some sort of corporation.
People don’t like this.
It’s commercializing!
Absolutely.
Shake your fist and say
“this doesn’t sound good”
if you want to.
And you’re going to wind up in a place where
the tax burden is insanely high.
I just think some things should be left pure,
not tainted by money.
You know what she should do?
Start a nonprofit,
raise 30 million dollars,
she can name it whatever she wants.
It’s one of the largest construction projects
in the country.
Our governor just had a beautiful new bridge built
and he named it after his father.
Yes he did.
That’s true.
Governor Mario M. Cuomo bridge.
We actually have an imperial bridge
named after our royal family.
I’m embarrassed.
Sharpe is the libertarian candidate.
We libertarians don’t worship politicians
and don’t think they deserve monuments,
just because they got elected.
I’ll tell you what I’ll do.
He’s got 30 million dollars a year?
He can keep his name on that bridge
and he needs to take care of the maintenance.
Someone asked me,
Larry, how are you going to pay for I-81?
Sharpe’s campaign is attracting new people.
His rallies have bigger crowds
than third party candidates normally get.
And Sharpe’s original ideas
helped get him speaking roles
at big events
and media coverage.
If you’re unhappy with the system,
you’ve got to change it.
One poll found Sharpe getting 13%
and after people hear his campaign pitch,
25% support him.
I’m not gonna roll back anything.
Some of Sharpe's positions surprised me.
You're a libertarian.
I assume you want to cut these wasteful programs.
Of course not.
Look, the issue here is
you don't want to just pull the rug out from people
because when you do that, they become afraid.
If people are afraid,
they rarely vote for you.
So you would keep all these government programs?
When did I say that was going away?
Yeah.
I said no new programs.
And you would keep the existing-
Sure.
Why ... who said I would get rid of them?
I never said that.
I just assumed because
Why?
They're inefficient, they're bloated, they're-
So get rid of them?
That's the worst idea.
Let me be very clear about something.
If you pull the rug out from somebody,
somebody's going to be afraid.
Sharpe focuses on his alternatives to taxes.
Why don’t we instead have a 3M bridge
or a Apple bridge,
or a Pepsi bridge?
Why hasn’t this been done?
Because no one has any new ideas.
There’s no ideas how I’m going to fix anything
or do anything right.
It doesn’t even exist.
I’m a third party.
I have to have ideas
or no one will listen to me.
The MTA, New York's subway system,
is falling apart.
Trains are packed, buses are packed.
We need the money.
So Sharpe says,
rent out the tracks at night.
We have so many lines on the MTA right now
that are not being used at all at night.
Home Depot or Google or Amazon
or whomever,
they can decide
they can use these freight lines,
they’ll help pay for maintenance obviously
and they’ll pay to move their freight.
Again, win-win-win.
Then Sharpe said something else that surprised me.
There are systems out there
that are both safe and unionized,
so we keep the unions happy
and our workers safe,
and be cheaper.
Why do you want to keep the unions happy?
Because they're unionized?
Why would I want not to keep unions happy?
Because unions can be destructive.
They can be, absolutely.
I don’t think of a libertarian as a pro-union guy.
Unions are part of our First Amendment.
It's people getting together
saying they won't do X until you do Y.
Nothing wrong with that at all.
It raises prices.
Fine, that's okay.
It is what it is.
Collective bargaining is fine.
My issue with the unions has always been
are you forcing me to be in a union?
Are you forcing unionized labor?
If you're forcing it, I'm libertarian.
I have a problem with that,
but you're voluntarily doing it?
I don't have a problem at all.
Sharpe is the rare politician
who proposes new ideas
that might actually reduce the burden
of government.
This man liked his subway-funding idea.
I think that would be good.
We need air conditioning in the subways,
so Amazon, get us air conditioning.
He’s thinking the right way.
Amazon will love it, we’ll love it.
I like that guy.
And I like it that there’s at least one candidate
who doesn’t want to make government
bigger.
New programs?
No. I'm libertarian.
No new programs?
No no no no no no no no.
That are going to take care of people?
You do know what party I am part of, right?
Libertarians believe
that you should be as conservative
or as liberal as you want to be,
as long as you don’t want to force yourself on others.
Larry Sharpe for Governor 2018.
Thank you very much.